[Music]
joining me now is gordon chang gatestone
institute senior fellow and author of
the great u.s china tech war
gordon within the last hour or so we've
learned that pelosi visited parliament
and did meet with the taiwanese
president we haven't seen a response
from china yet
but will they ramp up the threats and
will those threats turn into real action
china has to do something laura because
they made this a test of wills and it's
important for speaker pelosi to go and
actually be photographed that's the most
important thing you know the new york
times say oh this is just symbolic well
for people in a insecure totalitarian
state symbolism is everything and what
speaker pelosi said to people in taiwan
and people in the region people in the
world people in america was that we will
not be intimidated this is important
because if she didn't go
we would have been um emboldening the
worst elements in the chinese political
system by showing that intimidation
against america works this is a great
day for america
now the biden administration gordon um
it keeps distancing itself from pelosi
here was john kirby today
when the speaker of the house says we
stand with taiwan america stands with
taiwan how can the chinese construe that
as anything else but that you're
supporting independence
i'll let the speaker
speak
for herself we do not support taiwan
independence and nothing has changed
now gordon what does that response mean
for folks out there watching who don't
understand the nuances of this
relationship
yeah that response is basically
communist party talking points it said
kirby actually saying what beijing wants
him to say and you know biden has made
this problem worse he started doing that
on july 20 when he said to reporters oh
the pentagon doesn't think that the
speaker's trip is a good idea because
what he was saying to beijing was look
our administration is divided come in
and intimidate us some more and that is
in fact what happened laura because the
already dire sounding threats became
even more dire after president biden's
comments this became a real test of
wills because biden wouldn't support the
speaker of the house
now gordon some of my good friends
disagree
with my analysis your analysis of the
situation
i think this is an invaluable
important moment for the united states
because the establishment can't hide
anymore they can't kind of paper this
over
they're literally threatening
not so many words to shoot her plane out
of the sky
and they're like well let's do more
business with china let's drop the
tariffs on china let's enrich china what
the heck has that strategy gotten us
over the last 20 years
it's gotten us into a very dangerous
situation where there are no good
options on thursday when xi jinping
threatened biden basically threatened
the life of the president by saying that
those who would play with fire would
will perish you know biden should have
hung up the phone um instead we get
language from the white house readout
about the necessity of the deepening
communication to work with china in
areas where we agree you know china
looks at that and says we own the oval
office so this is a time where the
united states needs to stand together
and we need a president who is willing
to defend the united states instead of
just propagating communist party talking
points
gordon we really appreciate you tonight
especially of all knights thank you so
much hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else